e aí galera esse campeonato você está
bom e beleza e encanto bom não estou
feliz e ao mesmo tempo triste não estava
nem tanto no show do paulo estava com a
pulseirinha o fominha sampa canalha
bicho muito engraçado cara super gente
pudesse falar com a galera conversa com
pessoal acabou com a boa peça e vão
tirar foto e paulo estava aí que começa
o meu drama galera ele teve que sair
rápido porque tinha um voo para
fortaleza e eu não consegui tirar foto
com ele já que aimar do lado eram pose
ocorrem para o cheguei no aeroporto uma
fonte acaba de chegar de são paulo e fui
tirar foto comigo não vou tirar fotos no
meu celular descarregou não tem problema
eu tirei do meu irmão pra você iria
falar para quem gosta de quem gosta de
mim aqui e vote aqui
tire a forma que vai passar vou passar
pela taxa que passou a tap o número
chegou mais quatro favela foram tinha a
foto na foto tirada com a câmera tira a
foto quando eu olhei popular com o
estado entregando o prometido cara a
cara com gustavo entrou o dono sabe é o
pior disso tudo isso tudo é que ele
estava indo para fortaleza e amanhã ao
meio dia eu tô indo pra fortaleza ontem
antes de ontem fui comprar essa passagem
cheguei lá a mulher falou olha nós temos
voo olha nós temos vou meia noite temos
um meio de se prefere não o meia noite
porque é melhor chegar lá já adulto em
honra de carlos silvino volta de meio
dia que é mais tranquilo beleza foram
por meio de aí quem é e vai no vôo de
meia-noite paulo está torno de 8
disseram monson tudo tem que ser uma
cidade só hashtag números o estado
passava essa mulher é obrigado a
atendente daquele maldito balcão para
estragar tudo minha vida eu ia ficar lá
mas eu ia ficar lá na sala de embarque
com paulo gustavo e conversar com ele só
ia fumar ele ia pedindo
ainda lá equipe pode ficar pior para que
pode porque a vida minha mãe é uma peça
chama ao táxi ou chamar o táxi sai pra
casa e eu tenho um azar
eu só pego táxi de fortes pi moleque
fácil votar rápido conseguir a placa do
carro a lei não hoje eu pego um táxi que
preste hoje eu pego chamei um táxi
quando táxi parou o táxi escutam garota
[ __ ] no volume 45 para isso eu morro e
por força graças a deus cheguei em casa
vi publicado meteus aleluia do espanhol
oriente o pior de todo mês o tony tudo é
que agora me bateu um peso na
consciência porque ele era um pouquinho
ele é porque ele elas têm que isso meus
erros são duas pessoas então como notar
duas pessoas são duas pessoas com
paciência quero dizer eu quero
certificar e ele tava nem tão pertinho
de um eu não consegui
aí eu penso que eu faço standard quando
eu vou em algum lugar tem alguém que tem
alguém que não consegue tirar foto com
league ainda fechará deixe fã assistir
ou ouvir um ao outro dia me ver e dilma
como foi que eu fique mulher eu fiquei
hoje tudo você saber cara tão pertinho
você só depois por favor me tirar foto
comigo há anos não posso estou atrasado
no pertinho pertinho de button plena
consciência agora eu tô querendo estão
em alta o índice dá me a mim mesmo vou
me matar até o morrer é cruel demais
porque tem que ser assim disse o que o
ruim é que a culpa sempre um artista o
artista sempre ocupado este tinha ele
tinha ele tinha um vôo e não podia
perder o vôo e para começar com amigos e
ficou de passar nem para conversar
comigo
mas a vida é assim e deixar até uma fase
de reflexão para você melhor paulo
gustavo na mão do que dois litros no ano
8 triste mas se você der um líquido
nesse dia se você clicar no custeio já
íamos ficar muito feliz e vai ajudar
tanto na minha vida que toda pessoa que
é uma mata não quanto aquele que você
comentasse aqui embaixo quem é o seu
ídolo como ele aqui em baixo que a
pessoa possui hora todos admira na
ciência na na televisão teatro segunda
tanto faz como é que é o seu ídolo
também serve muito obrigado a não deixar
marcas no terminal até mais galera beijo
pra tanto irritado